[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts de l'actualité de la semaine à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avec à
mes côtés thibault note bon gentil
bonjour oriane est notre invité cette
semaine est annie genevard bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la députée les
républicains du doubs vous êtes
également vice présidente de l'assemblée
nationale merci d'être avec nous merci
et dans l'actualité parlementaire cette
semaine et bien il ya d'abord cette
image inédite mardi lors des questions
au gouvernement les présidents de tous
les groupes politiques ont accompagné le
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand dans l'hémicycle un
symbole d'unité après un incendie
volontaire à son domicile au sénat le
même message d'union sacrée a été
adressé en soutien à tous les élus visés
ces dernières semaines la loi écoles
débattu à l'assemblée elle prévoit
l'instruction obligatoire dès 3 ans le
ministre jean michel blanquer veut
placer son texte sous le signe de la
confiance mais il soulève cependant de
nombreuses inquiétudes
enfin la pédophilie au menu d'une
mission d'information au sénat elle a
été déclenchée après les scandales
survenus notamment au sein de l'église
catholique
des représentants de la conférence des
évêques de france ont été entendus cette
semaine et on commence cette semaine
avec l'union des parlementaires face aux
attaques dont ils sont l'objet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une députée qui retrouve son véhicule
brûlé des coups de feu devant le
domicile d'un autre parlementaire la
maison du président de l'assemblée
nationale
victime d'un incendie volontaire ces
actes inquiétants se multiplient depuis
plusieurs mois ils traduisent un
antiparlementarisme de plus en plus
violents en réaction les deux assemblées
ont voulu adresser un message de fermeté
et d'unité cette semaine
laszlo jalabert l'image et inédites
réunies derrière le président de
l'assemblée nationale les présidents des
huit groupes parlementaires font leur
entrée dans l'hémicycle sous les
applaudissements ainsi dignité contre
les violences envers les élus réunis ce
matin l'ensemble des présidents des
groupes de l'assemblée nationale a
condamné unanimement et avec la plus
grande fermeté les actes de violence
d'intimidation et de dégradations
commises à l'encontre des représentants
de la nation dernière événement en date
le 8 février dernier une tentative
d'incendié au domicile privé de richard
ferrand dans le finistère pour les
députés de tous bords pas question de
manquer à l'appel dans ces circonstances
troubles et rien ne justifie parce que
c'est un bien précieux rare et fragile
dans une démocratie d'attaqué de porter
atteinte à ceux qui sont son coeur
vivant et ceux qui sont ses
représentants c'est la première fois
depuis la création de la république que
le domicile du président de l'assemblée
nationale qui est le symbole de notre
liberté à tous de liberté à nous
parlementaires mais des citoyens que
nous représentons d'exprimer les
opinions symboliquement jean luc
mélenchon avec d'autres présidents de
groupe je prends ta compagne et tout à
l'heure le présent l'international pour
dire que quels que soient les désaccords
et les confrontations politiques
indispensables
font partie du quotidien du travail
parlementaire il est hors de question de
tolérer qui est des violences des
insultes etc
depuis le début du mouvement des gilet
jaune au mois de novembre
plusieurs dizaines de députés ont été
victimes d'actes de violence menace
permanente incendié au mur et des coups
de feu ont même été tirés devant le
domicile d'un député de la majorité et
le président du sénat gérard larcher a
fait part de son soutien à tous les élus
visés tout particulièrement au président
de l'assemblée nationale richard ferrand
annie genevard il était temps d'afficher
un tel message de fermeté de
condamnation de ces violences est ce
qu'une partie des doses d opposition n'a
pas trop tardé à le faire je ne sais pas
si véritablement votre question est
pertinente je crois qu'il faut retenir
de cet épisode la volonté unanime de
tous les présidents de groupes de dire
ça suffit
au delà du soutien normal que nous avons
apportées aux présidents de l'assemblée
nationale et aux députés qui ont été
victimes de ses agissements
il y a dans cette initiative la volonté
de dire notre démocratie
elle doit être défendue nous sommes les
représentants légitimes du peuple nous
avons été élus nous sommes là parce que
les français nous ont confié cette
responsabilité nous l'assumons avec je
crois beaucoup d'engagement et de
sérieux et on sait bien lorsqu'on
regarde derrière soi dans l'histoire
récente ou plus anciennes chaque fois
que l'on s'en prend la démocratie
représentative
chaque fois qu'on laisse s'épanouir
l'antiparlementarisme
on sait très bien à quelles extrémités
cela conduit toujours
donc je crois qu'il était temps en effet
de marquer symboliquement un coup
d'arrêt et surtout une unanimité
voilà donc on peut le vivez vous cet
antiparlementarisme grandissant à titre
personnel en tant qu'élu de la
république
ça me désole parce qu'il ya un hiatus
complet entre la façon dont
nous exerçons notre fonction dont nous
menons notre mandat
qui voit là et amanda très très exigeant
qui demande une présence un
investissement au détriment de sa vie
privée au détriment parfois de sa
famille qui exige beaucoup en ce moment
nous travaillons sur un texte de loi c
jour et nuit donc il ya une espèce de
sidération à se dire mais comment se
fait-il que ce travail que nous
conduisons n'est pas mieux compris des
français c'est la raison pour laquelle
les quais vous alors moi je crois que ce
qui est interrogé dans tout cela
bon d'abord ya un contexte politique
particulier que l'on connaît et puis ce
qui est clairement interrogé aussi c'est
l'efficacité de l'action politique et
moi qui a été une élue locale pendant 15
ans une mère je vois le hiatus qui a
entre l'efficacité de l'action politique
locale ou amer avec son conseil
municipal il décide il fait et les
habitants voient immédiatement ce qui ce
qui réalisait dès qu'on franchit une
étape dans la hiérarchie et enfin dans
l'éloignement
on voit bien que tout est très difficile
on est très fort pour les constats à les
constats on sait les faire on sait les
faire et les refaire d'une année à
l'autre mais changer les choses c'est
beaucoup plus difficile et je crois que
dans cet antiparlementarisme il ya aussi
l'interrogation qui pour le coup elle
est légitime de l'efficacité de l'action
politique
il ya des problèmes vous devez les
résoudre parce que on vous a élu pour ça
donc je crois que au delà de la
condamnation et des faits inacceptables
vous avez des permanences attaqué en a
toujours eu ce qui change là c'est qu'on
s'attaque aux personnes au domicile à la
famille et puis la gradation quand même
des anars justement une députée de la
majorité a dû prendre la décision de
recruter des agents de sécurité elle a
reçu des menaces d'une personne disant
qu'elle est lui jeté de l'acide au
visage elle paye ses agents de sécurité
avec ses frais de mandat autrement dit
avec leur enveloppe normalement avec
laquelle elle paie ses collaborateurs
parlementaires ce que ça vous semble
normal qu'une députés doivent payer pour
sa sécurité au détriment de son travail
parlementaire
non non bien sûr que non ce n'est pas
normal mais
il faut comprendre la crown qui
s'exprime vous avez évoqué ce député
dont le domicile a été l'objet de tirs
de balles que ce que vous voulez ce
genre de choses inquiète non seulement
le député mais sa famille j'imagine que
s'il a des enfants à son domicile
comment voulez-vous que on ne se
préoccupe pas de sécurité quand on a une
famille voilà donc non c'est pas c'est
pas une situation normale j'espère que
l'apaisement que nous appelons de nos
voeux pourra faire cesser ce type de
comportement j'observe aussi que et
c'est le dernier point le premier texte
de loi qui a été votée par la majorité
c'est un texte de défiance à l'égard des
élus c'est la loi dite loi de confiance
mais qui en réalité disait en creux vos
élus sont pas honnêtes on va les obliger
à l'être ça c'est un signe si la loi qui
a été vraiment vraiment très négatif
alors même qu'il se voulait qu'il
voulait restaurer la confiance il l'a un
peu plus grignotées et les attaques
contre les élus ne sont pas les seuls à
se multiplier ces dernières semaines
plusieurs actes antisémites ont aussi
marqué les esprits ces derniers jours
inscription sur des vitrines croix
gammée sur des portraits de simone veil
profanation d'un arbre en mémoire d'ilan
halimi
le premier ministre a dénoncé mardi l'
horreur qui se cache derrière ces gestes
imbéciles et le président du sénat
gérard larcher a lui aussi lancé un cri
d'alarmé on écoute quand plus aucun
symbole dé respecter
comment s'étonner de la résurgence de
comportement que nous pensions
définitivement appartenir au passé
la nausée que nous inspire la résurgence
de l'antisémitisme
tout comme les récents de profanations
d'églises renforce de notre
détermination à ne jamais rien fait d
quand l'essentiel est en jeu annie
genevard on entendu beaucoup de
condamnation de ces faits cette semaine
ne condamn é suffit-il on a l'impression
que d'une forme d'impuissance des
pouvoirs publics face à cette montée de
l'antisémitisme
plusieurs plans d'action ont été lancés
ces dernières années sans endiguer le
phénomène
comment faire
alors le mal est profond et anciens moi
je distinguerai deux choses ya des faits
graves est bouleversant c'est
l'assassinât d'ilan halimi
ce sont les c'est l'assassinât des
petits enfants et de leurs parents à
l'école de toulouse c'est la tacc de
l'hyper cacher c'est la mort de mireille
knoll c'est aujourd'hui la sculpte faite
à la mémoire de simone veil victimes de
la shoah donc il ya ces faits qui
suscitent la nausée la nausée parce que
évidemment comme l'a dit le président
larcher
on croyait cela on croyait que cela
appartenait au passé et que la shoah
avait finalement suffisait à éradiquer
cette abomination qui est
l'antisémitisme en réalité les chiffres
sont terrifiants puisqu'au delà de ces
de ces attaques les plus barbares les
plus visibles c'est l'antisémitisme du
quotidien qui progresse 74 % de
progression des faits antisémites
il a su culture internet les agressions
les bref on voit bien que c'est un
phénomène qui se développe
et il l'est résulte de plusieurs choses
d'abord je pense que l'islam radical a
fait des juifs c'est cible clairement
lien lien entre la progression de
l'islamisme politique radicale et la
montée de l'antisémitisme
deuxièmement il y à aussi je crois
cet antisionisme c'est cette qui court
dans l'opinion publique depuis des
décennies et qui font des juifs parce
que israël parce que le conflit israélo
palestinien
le terreau de cet antisémitisme et je
crois que notamment la gauche portent
une lourde responsabilité en ayant eu un
regard
finalement une analyse univoque de la
situation israélo palestiniennes ou au
fond n'a jamais pris la peine de de
considérer la complexité des deux côtés
et je pense que cet antisionisme est
aussi une nourriture de l'antisémitisme
mais vous avez raison de dire on fait
des plans ont fait des protestations
vais avoir cette belle manifestation
unitaire mardi prochain et c'est bien
mais il faut passer à la vitesse
supérieure a compté stablement paiement
puisque vous parlez simone veil la
sénatrice fabienne keller a proposé
cette semaine que marianne soit incarné
sous les traits de simone veil c'est une
initiative que vous allez souffrir alors
c'est une bonne une belle idée je trouve
d'autant que simone veil l'a été le
visage de l'europe qu'elle soit
aujourd'hui dans ces circonstances le
visage de la france me semble une bonne
idée
allez on en vient à notre deuxième thème
la loi pour une école de la confiance
débattu à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une loi sur l'école ce n'est jamais
anodin ça suscite toujours de vifs
débats celle ci ne fait pas exception si
sa mesure phare l'instruction
obligatoire dès trois ans est
globalement saluée sur tous les bancs
d'autres points du texte soulève des
inquiétudes ainsi les mesures pour
l'école inclusive intégrer dans la loi
sont jugées insuffisantes sur de
nombreux bancs résumé des débats signé
là selon sheila bair sur les bancs de
l'hémicycle jean michel blanquer a dû
répondre aux critiques
l'opposition juge que l'amendement du
gouvernement pour une école inclusive ne
va pas assez loin
il propose notamment de recruter les
accompagnants des élèves handicapés en
cdd pour une durée de trois ans eh bien
j'aimerais que l'on constate que ce
gouvernement a le triste privilège de
voir les oppositions chercher à tout
prix à décrire que à décrire nos
intentions comme n'étant pas ce qu'elle
soit j'essaie de cacher ma colère parce
que il ya un moment faut arrêter de nous
prendre pour des idiots et faut arrêter
de nous faire la leçon
- critiqué la mesure phare du texte rend
l'instruction obligatoire dès trois ans
soit 25 mille nouveaux enfants en
maternelle à la rentrée prochaine pour
les accueillir
certaines communes devront financer des
écoles privées sous contrat un coût de
100 millions d'euros selon jean michel
blanquer
le texte prévoit une compensation de
l'état mais pas pour les communes qui
subventionnait déjà ces écoles privées
on voit bien qu'on a un système qui est
totalement inéquitable
à partir du moment où vous avez une
commune qui va payer pour des enfants
qui sont scolarisés dans le privé à hier
il faut qu'elles soient remboursées
quel que soit ce qu'elle avait choisi de
faire avant le ministre de l'éducation
minimise l'impact de cette mesure on
sait pas d'un seul coup l'augmentation
des dépenses de toutes les communes de
france dans des proportions incroyables
très souvent et je l' ai déjà expliqué
hier ça ne se verra même pas parce que
du fait de la démographie à 60 mille
élèves en moins l'année prochaine en
france les bancs de la gauche redoute
une mauvaise utilisation de l'argent
public et je trouve que 100 à 150
millions d'euros de contribution
financière supplémentaire pour l'école
privée sans contrepartie
je pense que c'est déraisonnable il
faudrait qu'il y ait une contrepartie au
fil des discussions le projet de loi a
été modifiée
les formulaires scolaire ne porteront
plus les mentions père nerfs mes parents
1 et par an 2 la marseillaise et les
drapeaux français et européens devront
être affichées dans chaque classe le
projet de loi devrait être votée en
première lecture mardi prochain alors ni
genevard d'abord cette mesure phare du
texte le passage de la scolarité de 6 à
3 ans ou mais cette mesure est ce qu'il
n'est pas surtout symbolique ce que 95 %
des élèves et il est déjà scolarisé
oui en effet ça concerne un peu plus de
vingt mille enfants bon moi je ne suis
pas hostile par principe parce que on
sait bien que la réussite d'un enfant
elle dépend de la précocité de
l'acquisition de son vocabulaire par
exemple et je pense que pour certains
enfants une scolarisation plus précoce
leur permettra une acquisition plutôt
d'un vocabulaire nécessaires à la
réussite scolaire pour autant ça pose
quelques questions d'abord la question
de la fatigue des enfants
vous le savez bien les petits les plus
petits vont parfois à l'école de mater
rsa la maison l'après midi pour faire la
sieste ou les parents le savent bien les
enfants sont très fatigués à bhl à cet
âge là ils ont besoin de dormir de se
reposer donc à la question effectivement
de 2 du fait que les familles désormais
n'auront plus ce choix de s'adapter au
rythme d'un très jeune enfant se pose
aussi la question du financement vous
l'avez vu puisque évidemment scolarisés
davantage des lèvres à un coût pour les
communes et
là les communes qui finançait déjà la
scolarisation dès 3 ans ne seront pas
aidés en revanche celle qui viendrait le
sont donc il ya une forme d'injustice et
alimentaire pour les collectivités
contrairement à ce que dit la mine
hassaï est sûre c'est une charge
supplémentaire puisque à l'école
maternelle vous devez fournir des locaux
vous devez fournir du matériel
vous devez fournir de l'accompagnement
avec les atsem donc bien sûr ça a un
coût non négligeable qui est aux
alentours de 800 euros par enfant et par
an
donc c'était évident que si on se
polarise davantage d'enfants les coûts
seront supérieures alors autre mesure
finalement adopté dans cette loi mardi
la reconnaissance de l'homoparentalité
dans les formulaires scolaire les mots
pères et mères seront remplacés par les
mentions parents et la vendeuse qu'en
pensez vous moi je trouve ça assez
affligeant je trouve ça assez affligeant
parce que voilà une députée qui a
justifié sa démarche en disant écoutez
sur ton d'un système qui est à rire et
de sortons de schémas dépassés
enfin on est dans quelque chose de
complètement absurde comme si 95% des
enfants connaissent aujourd'hui
l'identité de leur père et de leur mère
même si les parents de gifler ensemble
même si les parents vivent avec d'autres
personnes du même sexe ou pas mais un
enfant il a un père et une mère il les
connaît dans l'immense majorité des cas
donc cet effacement dans les documents
administratifs du père et de la mère me
semble tout à fait regrettable et comme
ça a été écrit par un éditorialiste
s'est profondément triste parents un
parent de en plus ça pose la question la
hiérarchie parce que 1 et 2 bat asia le
premier piel deuxième qui est le premier
qui est le deuxième
donc on va entrer dans des
considérations qui sont un peu
un peu absurde mais au-delà de ça je
pense que ce qui est à l'oeuvre là c'est
une finalement une préparation des
débats qu'on va avoir sur la loi
bioéthique et on va vers une
indifférenciation sexuée des parents
et clairement cela cela prépare les
débats que nous aurons sur sur la pma
sans père moi je pense que il s'agit pas
de remettre en cause les choix des
parents mais d'affirmer tout de même un
modèle qui je crois a fait ses preuves
depuis le début de l'humanité et surtout
vouloir imposer par une minorité sa loi
à la majorité
moi je trouve que ça pose vraiment
problème et j'ajoute pour finir que la
rapport le rapporteur et le ministre qui
ont émis un avis défavorable ne l'ont
pas émises au titre du fonds ils ont dit
ah ben on est d'accord sur le fond donc
on est d'accord sur l'esprit de cet
amendement simplement c'est pas d'ordre
législatif
moi j'espère vraiment que le sénat fera
sauter cette disposition et qu'on
reviendra un peu de raison un mot
rapidement sur cet autre amendement
adopté les drapeaux dans les classes les
paroles de la marseillaise affichés sont
pas des mesures un peu old school si
vous me passez l'expression au contraire
vous dites c'est salutaire
alors moi je pense que c'est tout sauf
le hall scouts parce que au fond ce sont
des symboles intemporel de la nation le
drapeau la marseillaise
ce sont voilées symbole d'unité de la
nation autour desquels la nation on peut
se rassembler et vouloir
l'enseigné aux enfants dès le plus jeune
âge enfin bon sens qui a t'il le
provocateur dans la présence du drapeau
français
alors le gouvernement pour est ce qu il
pouvait quand même pas s'opposer à la
présence du drapeau dans les écoles mais
pour en affaiblir un peu la portée que
certains jugent trop nationaliste enfin
dans un commentaire que moi je trouve
assez hallucinant a souhaité y adjoindre
le drapeau européen
pourquoi pas mais on a entendu des
choses invraisemblables l'école devienne
caserne
c'est l'expression du nationalisme le
plus étroit en fait tout ça il faut il
faut revenir un peu plus de raison on va
avancer on va passer à ce qui se passe
au sénat puisque la mission d' enquête
sur les infractions sexuelles sur mineur
poursuivi ses travaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'église catholique face aux scandales
d'abus sexuels c'est une audition très
attendue qui a eu lieu cette semaine
devant les sénateurs est celle de la
conférence des évêques de france son
secrétaire général a reconnu un
aveuglement de la surdité du déni mais a
refusé de parler d'omerta réseau retour
sur cette audition avec sandra serre car
il refuse de parler d'omerta mais
reconnaît de l'aveuglément et du déni
vis-à-vis des abus sexuels commis par
des membres du clergé
monseigneur ribadeau-dumas auditionné
par la mission d'information du sénat a
tenu à reconnaître la responsabilité des
évêques dans les actes pédophiles mine
elle dans le fait de ne pas les avoir
traités correctement dans le fait
d'avoir été sourd aux cris des victimes
et en même temps notre détermination à
ce que demain est aujourd'hui même mais
demain il n'y ait plus ces actes là et
donc que toutes les actions que nous
menons aujourd'hui que nous mènerons
dans l'avenir servent pour qu' il n'y
ait plus de pédocriminalité au sein de
l'église catholique et que nous
collaborions fait qu'il n'y en ait plus
au coeur de la société française les
sénateurs disent avoir apprécié la
franchise des interventions et salue une
véritable prise de conscience
ils ont répondu sans tabou c'est la
première fois c'est vrai que j'entends
des évêques parler de sexualité parler
de formation des séminaristes parler de
choses qui jusqu'à présent étaient
plutôt qu dans l'église et avec une
vraie conscience des victimes et de
leurs drames
la conférence des évêques a décidé de
mettre en place une commission d'enquêté
indépendante présidée par jean marc
sauvé ancien vice-président du conseil
d'état eut nous ne souhaitons en aucun
cas nous substituer à la justice
concurrencer la justice en revanche nous
ce qui nous est demandé c'est de faire
un point global de situation les
différents cas d'abus sur mineurs depuis
1950 vont être étudiés la commission
réunit des experts de plusieurs
disciplines
même si certaines victimes regrette de
ne pas y être représentés elle rendra un
rapport d'ici deux ans alors annie
genevard avec vous d'accord avec les
propos du secrétaire général de la
conférence des évêques quand il dit
qu'il n'y a pas eu
omerta l'omerta signifierait que il y a
eu l'organisation d'un silence pour
couvrir des faits dont on connaît la
gravité et dont on mesure l'horreur bon
j'entends la parole de l'évêque je suis
porté à le croire
néanmoins aujourd'hui il est clair que
d'une part la lumière doit être faite je
pense que l'initiative de l'allée des
évêques de france est une bonne
initiative ya à la fois une démarche à
faire roussanne l'église je crois que
c'est c'est salutaire il faut faire
confiance je crois à l'église pour
éradiquer cette abomination
il y a aussi ce qui relève de la justice
des hommes et qui doit poursuivre son
chemin
donc voilà on verrait que l'église a mis
du temps trop de temps à prendre
conscience de ce qui se passait en son
sein alors je pense que sur cette
question de la pédophilie
l'ensemble de la société a mis du temps
à entendre la parole des victimes
on voit aujourd'hui que toutes les
structures humaines peuvent être
concernés par par ces crimes et que
aujourd'hui et bien c'est toute la
société dans toutes ses dimensions dans
toute son organisation et
particulièrement dans les structures qui
sont en contact avec les mineurs qui
doit porter une vigilance absolue à
l'éradication et à la punition très
sévère de ces actes qu'ils détruisent
qui détruisent des vies
donc voilà je ne peux qu'encourager mais
malheureusement ça ça touche l'église
comme ça touche toutes les structures
humaines
il n'ya pas de spécificité de te les
jeunes croît m une des questions qui est
posée par la mission la mission aura à y
répondre à cette question et l'aide elle
est difficile et douloureuse hâtivement
je dirais qu'il n'ya pas de spécificité
c'est malheureusement le propre de toute
organisation humaine ou sont en contact
des enfants avec des adultes des
voiliers et criminel donc voilà
ce qu'on peut dire à ce stade merci
merci beaucoup et les jeunes verts
d'avoir été avec nous cette semaine
merci thibault sur yon se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
semaine d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]